you ever go for a walk in the woods
you ever go out playing the ukulele on
the moon at night you ever see strange
Stars moving in the sky you ever heard a
blood curdling scream in the middle of a
swamp
you ever eaten an onion welcome to
incident in the grave Lake Grove Lake
I'm still a little sick I'm doing good
though I just wanted to get one more in
before I Collapse on the couch but I'm
gonna play this I might be slightly
loopy or I might be slightly ridiculous
or not speaking clearly but that isn't
going to stop me from being adopted
abducted by aliens because that's what
this is about and I'm gonna strip naked
I'm gonna wander out in into Area 51 I'm
in a Naruto run butt naked and I'm gonna
oil myself up so that their bullets just
slide right off they won't be able to
catch me I'll be too slippery
I thought this game was going to be
about getting abducted by an alien I
think that actually we're gonna go into
Area 51 and abduct us an alien so that
we can have it in our home
him her it
September 6 1997 front gate
I think that was a car leaving area 51.
so if that is us then we is stealing
aliens
hello
oh
am I being hacked
not being hacked
if this pulls up my webcam I'm gonna be
very very
intrigued
[Music]
oh
okay
I think I've seen this movie accessing
audio
oh okay
appreciate you taking my call hello
let's get this straight you got out
unnoticed medical discharge they think I
have kidney stones
as smart as they think it S4 huh smarter
than you know so we meet
sure let's make it a public place
remember I don't have a lot of time
neither do I let's say the diner at
Brook dark did
works for me I'll bring what I found
good I'll see you soon remember what I
have risked for this I remember
okay
I don't remember what I risked for this
somewhere north of Nevada
September 9th 1997.
hello
hi oh nope don't go that way
hello you ever take a walk alone on the
sidewalk
you ever walk faster away from someone
screaming at you across the road you
ever feel like you've been transported
back to the 90s
you ever pick both nostrils at the same
time hey someone else to harass
hello oh yeah I was supposed to go to
dining
is that a diner diner hey
are you who I'm meeting hi it's me the
guy from the aliens all right fine
or you know hey hello
Aaron all right
wow it's quiet in here
how are you hi good to see you I'm a
little sick anyway have a good day I was
up nice coffee all right
my breakfast hello talk to stranger
I am here
thank you for coming
I didn't know who else to tell
I've risked so much getting here
following me are they
I can't imagine I'm not suspicious at
all I don't have much time please take
these some files and just one of the
many tapes they have get this stuff to
the public
they need to know before it's too late
if I don't hear from you by the 11th I'm
going public with this
September 11th there's a radio station I
know of you know no you know of I don't
know please go and be careful they'll
follow you too
joint
okay oh
I'm not in the car
I was just showing that they were fall
ah I see
okay I got it
is this my home
hello
pick up tape I guess I played the tape
sure
the following tape is prop property of
the United States government incident
number 17 example of encounter type f
copying or distribution of this tape is
strictly prohibited classification of
this content is reserved to members with
tssi SCI clearance the following took
place August 19th through the 21st and
1997 Grove Lake the tape was discovered
and handed to local authorities
September 97.
please contact your facility supervisor
on conclusion of this tape as outlined
in section 4B okay I mean I can't follow
the rules if I can't read them so it's
not my fault
oh hello
oh
lovely this
have I ever taken a walk in the middle
of the forest on a
blood moon lit day
is this a siren head game
as someone I haven't thought about in a
long time there's quite a few cyanide
games that I haven't played either
but there's some good ones that I missed
um do people normally film themselves
walking in the woods like this where
it's just a camera straight pointed
ahead I'm gonna guess there must be it's
got to be like YouTubers that specialize
in content and just wandering around in
the woods I'm sure someone's documented
their trip up like the Appalachian
trailer like the rocky or the Pacific
Trail the one that goes from Mexico to
Canada oh
it's camping with Steve maybe
oh I saw that
Lexi and do a replay
[Music]
anyone watching on their tiny little
itty bitty phone all you people watching
on this little tiny screen you never
would have seen that but you never felt
called out before listen ever since you
guys watched in space with markiplier
exclusively on your phone I will never
forgive you
that was meant to be enjoyed on at least
a TV screen at least a laptop come on
let's look
like
no is that a skull
no it's just a weird white stain on the
ground
can't imagine what that was
weird what
wasn't nearly scary enough looks even
make that scarier
nah scarier come on elevated a little
bit nah come on really spook him really
blast them out of their eyeballs all
right
now the next one that happens got to be
even scarier just so you know it's a
rule of escalation I don't make the
rules I make the rules which is why you
got to follow the rules
you can't be mad at me I'm sick
all right
Oh I thought that was a person
it's a radio
okay anyway whatever someone uh who's
never been scared before was scared or
something like that I don't know
well I'm certainly not scared just going
out for a walk in the woods
as you do
so many people do this all the time
nothing weird
okay
what pleased her what we will now review
the four types of what
what
visual sightings of an object on an
unidentified seemingly less than 500
feet away that show an appreciable
angular extension in considerable detail
okay
the second kind UFO event with physical
effects such as interference animal
reactions or physical Trace like
impressions of the ground scorched or
otherwise affected vegetation or a
chemical Trace
okay
OH Close Encounters of the ah I didn't
oh UFO Encounters in which an animated
entity is present do these include
humanoids robots and humans who seem to
be occupants or Pilots of a UFO
all right
ah a close encounter of The Fourth Kind
is a UFO event in which a human is
abducted by a UFO or its occupants okay
please identify on your workbook or any
further encounter types oh
yeah
it's a light
there's two three
my object
met my object drinking is just
unparalleled
oh wait a minute
should I look up I'm gonna be on the
watch out
those second kinds ain't gonna get away
from me thirds Maybe
is that a goat
no this is the second kind don't worry
guys it's just a second encounter it's
just an encounter of the second kind
no need to panic
are you just a type too
that ain't nothing
ain't nothing to be scared of
nowhere
oh it's just a house guys don't worry
foreign
oh
you all right bud
oh far it's your four
oh ah good thing he also had a camera on
his uh face
what was that lexian did you see that
Flash oh that's what that was never mind
false alarm
but that doesn't look good
well that doesn't look any better
am I no I am ah
oh
ah
who knew aliens meat just a bunch of
meat oh good
did you have a Fourth Kind
oh
okay
oh good
oh it's a party
all right
why not
I gotta say
um
I don't know if this is like
paths that they the aliens walk
to get
to various places on the ship
seems inefficient
[Music]
door is very efficient what do I know
I'm just a dumb human
oh nope
I'm sliding or I'm being dragged
oh I'm fine
all's good
we're good
so how
how
does that benefit him
the tape is now concluded no further
footage was recoverable tape will be
added archive section four
please now contact your supervisor for
psycho Alan Alice and debrief
okay form 52 up uh
your discretion is a matter of National
Security please remember your oath and
those who came before you
what
or what
oh okay
so uh the alien's gonna like know
oh no the government's Gonna Know
ah
you see it's like
number 10th now so I just spent a few
days waffling about this
oh could that be
well
oh
visitors
of guests
oh hey wait a minute
listen
we are
you already had that all right
huh talk show host Art Bell receives a
frantic call from a man claiming to have
worked in area 51. fine you're on the
air hello
hello art yes hi um I I I don't have a
whole lot of time
um well look let's begin by finding out
whether you're using this line properly
or not error area 51. that's right were
you an employer or are you now uh a
former employee I was let go on a
medical discharge about a week ago and
and
I I've kind of been running across the
country
um oh man I don't know where to start
there
they're gonna
um they'll triangulate on this position
really really soon you can't spend a lot
of time on the phone so give us
something quick okay
um
okay well what we're thinking of as as
aliens are there
uh they're they're extra dimensional
beings that
an earlier precursor of the um the Space
Program made contact with uh they they
are not what they claim to be
uh they have infiltrated a lot of uh
a lot of aspects of of the military
establishment particularly the area 51
uh the disasters that are coming they
military I'm sorry the government knows
about them and there's a lot of safe
areas in this world that they could
begin moving the population to now art
but they're not doing they're not doing
anything they're not they want the major
population centers wiped out
so that the few that are left will be
more easily controllable
discharge
I I started
well I think we all can conclude
whatever it was we needed to conclude
from this adventure definitely not
topical considering uh things that are
in the news
who knows damn what a fun game thank you
everybody so much for watching hope you
enjoyed that hopefully you don't go
walking out in the woods on a moon late
night cause you never know what kind of
encounter you'll encounter could be an
alien
could be a bear equally as deadly and
it'll more most both likely to leave you
screaming
um
from dying was that alien abduction any
worse than being attacked by a bear
both are going to kill you so
well whatever I'm gonna die to a bear or
die to interdimensional aliens
it's all the same and uh we have a new
drop cloak Arcana very um very cool
stuff I definitely have taken uh the
pictures that I needed to take for that
I gotta do that thank you once again
have a lovely day don't think about this
in the middle of the night
and as always
I will see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]